BUT I THINK PLAYERS RIDE THAT KE
TALKED ABOUT.
IN FRONT.
REBOUND.
>> Answer: SPUN BY LARKIN OFF
THE SIDE OF THE NET.
RAYMOND TRYING TO TUCK IT IN
FRONT.
STILLD
THAT'S STOP SICK SIDE.
NICE SAVE BY THOMASTHE.
PASS KEPT IN AT THE LINE BY
FRONT..
THERE'S THE FAKE SHOT AND THAT
ONE OFF THE ARMED AHEAD BY LILJD
THE BACKHAHA
HE WAS DRAFTED AS A HOT GOAL
SCORER, AND
THERE.
ALLOWS THE SHOT TO GO THROUGH.
THIS IS ONE FOR
ENTIRE TIME.
THIS IS A SHOT PASS THA
KERFOOT, AND NOW THE LEAFS HAVEO
AND VE QUICK REACTION TAPE
TO TAPE.
AND GO TO THE NET, STICK ON THE
ICE.
THIS IS A GOAL
WAS ALL BUSINESS -- PUCK INTO
THE CREASE.
MATTHEAVARES.
HE'S ON HIS OFF SIDE.
YOU CAN SEE WITHIN
ONE AS NAMESTNIKOV HAS DETROIT'.
BUT IT'S VELENO WHO SCORED THE
ONE GOAL
KASE AWAY.
>> Chris: DAVID KAMPF ON THE
DRAW.
WINS IT AWAY
AND HE'LL TAKE IT ANY WAY  ONE
IT'S A ONE GOAL GAMM OFF THE STF
MRAZEK.
AND THIS IS